when you look back to Manchester United
days which was when you first got
involved with UNICEF why then over all
the other charities because I imagine
you must have been bombarded with
requests from everybody who'd like to
have been associated with you why did
you decide to get involved with UNICEF
well obviously my work with with UNICEF
started over 10 years ago with mass
united like you said you know started in
Thailand where I visited a center for
children that that were homeless and
needed help in certain situations so my
work with UNICEF started then and then I
had a letter and a phone call from Kofi
Annan asking me to be you know an
ambassador ambassador for for obviously
the organization and that was something
that obviously I was I was very proud of
and something that I was honored to be
actually asked to get involved with this
and obviously ten years on you know the
work that I've done over the last ten
years majority it's been children base
because you know that's something that
is obviously very passionate I'm very
passionate about and something that I
really love to be involved in so there's
certain situations that I've gone to you
know in South Africa and in Sierra Leone
and obviously the Philippines pretty
recently so the work that I've done with
UNICEF over the years has been something
that I've really enjoyed something that
I've been honored to be part of but you
know I've set up here you know we've set
up this this this fund the seven fund
which has never been done by UNICEF
before and we've been talking about it
for quite a few quite a few months about
how I can make a difference in in
different ways and the seven fund is
something that we are setting up where
you know we have seven different regions
and seven different initiatives that
we're going to be working on but that
also doesn't alienate or the other work
that I do you know in on the emergency
side you know when there are emergencies
there are devastations you know I will
still work on that but obviously these
initiatives are something that we've sat
down discuss with UNICEF and you know
that really do need urgent attention
that also doesn't alienate the other
charities that I have worked with over
the years I do have obviously many
people coming to me and asking me to be
involved in certain
and obviously you can't do every single
one by I try to do as many as possible
and over the years I've worked with you
know the NSPCC I've worked with the
Armed Forces I've worked with
comic relief Sport Relief and that's
something that I'll continue to do that
doesn't you know this doesn't you know
stop me doing those things it also adds
to that but you know the seven fund is
something that obviously I'm very proud
of UNICEF are very proud of and it's
exciting times you know you're a dad
before how hard you find it when you
travel to these places like Sierra Leone
and like the Philippines and see kids
who compared to your children's life and
and and their quality of life and their
hopes and dreams that their lives are so
so different how hard is that it I
wouldn't say it's hard because you know
I was well aware of when I put myself
you know up for being an ambassador of
UNICEF you have to be aware that you are
going to go into certain situations
where you're not used to and you're
going to see things that are going to
make you emotional you know and I try to
never get emotional on these trips it's
very hard not in front in front of
people you know I really try not to but
I think you know when you have four
children like I have four children at
home they're healthy they're happy they
do live a good life I make sure my
children are well aware of exactly what
I'm doing you know my little girl was
you know three-and-a-half years old so
she's a little bit too young but she
still knows that daddy goes away he
helps people helps children and then
comes back and shows her the pictures of
exactly what he's been doing my eldest
you know he's almost 16 and he's nearly
at the age where he actually can start
coming on the trips with me and really
understanding it and I'm lucky that my
children really understand exactly what
I do and what I do and while I'm why I'm
involved in UNICEF they understand that
I go away and help on different on
different areas and different ways and
different children obviously one thing
with with kids you can tell them all you
want sometimes they listen sometimes
they don't but what's great about you
know kids in general you know when you
show them something visually they really
respond well to that you know I love
photography one of the things that I do
on every
trip that I do with UNICEF is I take my
camera everywhere I take pictures and
then I go back and I show my family I
show my children and and they respond to
that and even this morning you're on the
school run before I arrived here you
know I'm taking Brooklyn to school and
he's saying when can I come on a trip I
understand what you're doing today when
can I start doing stuff so you know my
children understand it yes they do have
a great life yes they are very
privileged but they also understand
exactly what daddy does they understand
how they can kind of get involved and
and they really do want to help